الركاب المزعجون وكيف يمكننا
التعايش معهم
على متن طائرة هي نفس الطريقة التي يكون لديك بها
جيران في منطقتك
باستثناء أنه بدلاً من أن يكونوا في شقة
أو منزلك المجاور، فإنهم يشبهونك بجوارك
مباشرةً، ويحبونهم
خلفك مباشرةً  "لقد مررنا جميعًا
بتجربة ضخمة في صالة المطار، والآن
تحملنا هذا الضغط وذهبنا
إلى كبسولة صغيرة، فقط أعط الجميع
فترة راحة ليستقروا،
هناك بالتأكيد حقوق غير معلن عنها بشأن
مقعد الطائرة، مقعد النافذة
بسيط جدًا  يحصل على الحق في الوصول إلى
النافذة إذا كانوا يرغبون في تظليلها،
فهم يحافظون على الظل أعلى مقعد الممر
ولا يمكنهم إخبار شخص مقعد النافذة
بوضع الظل أسفل مقعد الممر، هذا
هو مقعدي المفضل الذي أحبه لأنه
يمكنني أن أكون نطاقًا حرًا  يشعر الراكب
وكأن لدي مساحة أكبر في
المقعد الأوسط، فهم يحصلون على أي شيء
يريدونه، وهما اثنان من مساند الذراعين، إذا كان
مقعد النافذة ومقعد الممر
يحملان أذرعهما هنا، فلديك كل
الحق فقط في دفعهما ببطء،
فهل أتكئ  نعم ولا أنا لا
أتكئ إذا كانت الرحلة أقل من ثلاث ساعات
على مدى ثلاث ساعات أريد أن أشعر
بالراحة لذا نعم سأجيب
ماذا تفعل عندما يكون شخص ما فظًا
وربما لا يعرف ذلك وكيف
يجب عليك التعامل معه  لقد حصلت مؤخرًا على
قطعتي علكة كانتا عاليتين جدًا
وكانا معًا عندما فرقعتا، كنت
سأذهب
ولم يلتقطاها
حتى تتمكن من تقديم طلب مهذب أو
يمكنك القيام بما فعلته وتوثيق
تجربة الركاب الأكثر إزعاجًا.  لقد كان هناك
امرأة على متن رحلة جوية
خلعت حذائها وجواربها ووضعت
قدميها العاريتين على مسند ذراعي على الفور،
لا أشعر بأي مشكلة، فقط استدرت
وقلت من فضلك لا تفعل ذلك ولكن
عليك أولاً توثيق
أنك لا تفعل ذلك  تريد إظهار وجوههم بشكل صحيح،
هذا ليس فضحًا، هذا فقط حتى
تتمكن من التعامل، كما أنها أعطت وقتًا لرفيقها
شريكها ليقول آه، يجب أن
تتذكر أنها تلتقط صورًا لهم
في النهاية يا رفاق، أنتم على متن طائرة.
وسائل النقل العام أربع ساعات وخمس
ساعات يمكننا التعامل معها